cloud computing has become an essential
part of every business's strategy and
companies big and small are using the
cloud in some or the other way to
enhance their competence
this begs the question
who exactly is helping them with this
cloud architects
hello and welcome to simply learn's
cloud architect masters program
cloud architects are it specialists who
have the skills and knowledge to
navigate complex cloud environments lead
teams develop and implement cloud
strategies and ensure cloud systems stay
up to date and run smoothly fortunately
for you they're a rare breed and that's
why they're in such demand with
companies going all out and paying cloud
architects average salaries of 129
000 us dollars
is our cloud architect program the right
choice for you
our cloud architect matches program is
aligned with aws microsoft azure and
google cloud platforms and provides you
with world-class training and skills
required to be successful the program
offers extensive training to master the
architectural principles and services of
the top cloud platforms design and
deploy highly scalable fault tolerant
applications with exposure to over 40
plus in demand skills and 25 plus
services
what makes this program different
our master's programs are specifically
role aligned and helps develop skills
for real career growth with capstone
projects in three domains and 16 plus
real-life projects as you learn this
program is a great choice for both new
and experienced professionals
other key benefits of the program
learn from experts active in the field
work on real world problems
get 24 7 learning support learn with
live virtual sessions
don't miss out on a great career
opportunity join the cloud architect
masters program today
[Music]